[Villagers stand next to water pump.]
[Female villagers mill about in food market, many carrying babies or with infants strapped to their backs as they work.]
[A group of children at the food market.]
[A Caucasian man dressed in a suit walks toward a western-style house built on pilings, with a screened porch.]
[Images of area buildings, homes, and huts.]
[A man plays with a small dog.]
[A man wearing white clothing and a wide-brimmed hat walks toward a house with scaffolding set up around it.]
[Villagers at work, constructing a building.]
[Two men, one white, one black, emerge from a thatch-roofed structure and continue walking.]
[Villagers gather outside a thatch-roofed structure; they mill about a table with small items on display.]
[Villagers with animals.]
[Images of animals.]
[Men carry large bundles on their heads and wade through knee-deep water towards dugout canoe..]
[Villagers next to boats, woman speaking and gesticulating]
[African troops are lined up outside a brick edifice, observed by Caucasian officers.]
[Men cover the opening through which they just walked, using a large tarp.]
[Two white men and a black man carry out mosquito collection tasks, one man digging down between two wooden boards, another operating a pump.]
[The men examine a flask and pump a substance into a hole in the ground.]
[The two men walk to the river's edge and scoop water into a container.]
[The black man is seen perched in the branches of a tree. He extends his leg toward the white man on the ground, who offers an object that the man in the tree grasps with his toes. This action is repeated.]
[A Caucasian man in a laboratory holds up a vial and examines its contents, then writes on the vial.]
[A chained monkey bounces about.]
[The monkey paws at a Caucasian man's scalp.]
[Down the Ogun River in Nigeria]
[Villagers work and move about at the river's edge.]
[A man propels a canoe with a pole.]
[Images of trees and plants along the river's edge.]
[Villagers sit in a canoe, one holding a long pole across his lap.]
[An African man propels a canoe with two visible passengers, one African and one Caucasian.]
[Villagers in boats on the river.]
[Villagers on shore, working and looking out over the river.]
[Woman stands in boat containing several large clay vessels, propelling it with a pole.]
[Children run through reeds and growth on riverbank, women carrying babies follow.
[Villagers gather as a canoe is docked.]
[Scenes in Oshogbo at End of Ramadan]
[Native men blowing horns, beating drums, waving parasols.]
[White-robed and turbaned villagers celebrate in the market square, a man on horseback is shown.]
[Villagers in white robes and turbans celebrate.]
[From Oshogbo to Ogbomosho]
[Villagers with bagged and loose crops, seemingly cotton, on the ground.]
[Women sitting on the ground, working with cotton, spinning and stretching it.]
[Men crowd the back of a vehicle already packed with crops and other men.]
[Large clay pots and other vessels; man walks in background.]
[Children are seen, with large clay pots in the foreground.]
[Road to Ibadan]
[Livestock are herded by shepherds.]
[Scenes in Ibadan]
[People selling goods at market.]
[Women walk with bundles on their heads.]
[Crocodile head and snout.]
[Woman shaving man's head]
[Woman digging and filling bowl with dirt]
[Shepherds with livestock]
[Villagers washing clothing, using buckets and other vessels.]
[Villagers standing, pounding grain.]
[Caucasian man in hat approaches thatch-roofed structure and ducks into it.]
[A Trip to Iwopin in Nigeria]
[Native men in canoes on the water toss out fishing lines and nets.]
[Caucasian man sits on stool looking at printed material, villagers observing him.]
[Caucasian man holding papers or mail hands a box to another man, who walks away. An African man standing next to him points.]
[Caucasian man holding rolled-up papers approaches colorfully-clothed African woman.]
[Caucasian man sits on stool in front of thatch-roofed structure surrounded by villagers.]
[Images of thatch-roofed and other village structures.]
[Trooping the Colors in Lagos]
[African troops in uniform march in formation across a field, led by Caucasian officers, including one on horseback.]
[The Beiram Festival of the Mohammedans in Lagos]
[Livestock in street, children milling about, one with sticks of wood bundled to his head]
[Villagers with turbans moving through streets, some on horseback, carrying flags]
[Boats moored at shore]
[Men gather, playing instruments, dancing, carrying parasols]
[Robed men at prayer, bowing down and rising up, then kneeling]
[Children and livestock in street, white man cradling African baby, whom he then hands to an older child]
[White man talks with children and takes the hand of a small baby held by an older child]
[People in the street, sitting on steps and walking about, children roughhousing]
[School on a Lagos Street.]
[Children standing near a teacher and his wooden desk, outdoors]
[Students reading from text]
[Natives and their Homes in Lagos]
[Woman walking with bundle on her head and baby strapped to her back]
[Bearded man in robes, wearing turban, holding open parasol above his head and then closing it]
[Nude child hurries down alley-like path with modest structures and firewood stacked on both sides of the path]
[Woman with a half-smile holds baby, with other smiling women standing next to her, pointing to and touching baby]
[Nude children running in street]
[Men in village square, pounding grain, pumping, pulling rickshaw-like vehicle with an occupant]
[Several men standing, one holding a baby, another wearing sunglasses and carrying a long cigarette-holder]
[Livestock]
[African troops march, then stop and perform maneuvers, instructed by Caucasian officers who walk down the line of troops, surveying]
[Troops march, carrying rifles]
[An Official's Home in Iyoki]
[Images of grounds of large house, birds, a cat and a dog being petted]
[A Tennis Party at the Medical Research Institute]
[A game of mixed doubles tennis is played on a clipped lawn with a net set up, the players dressed in tennis whites]
[A group of spectators sit in chairs observing the players]
[Tennis game continues]
[Villagers carrying bundles oj their heads dump the contents of the bundles into a square wooden, aboveground box; water is poured from a container onto the ground nearby]
[Bulls stand in field, stroked by a shepherd]
[A Caucasian man dressed in white with African villagers on either side of him smiles at the camera]
[Two African villagers sitting on wooden boxes scrub garments in a large tub of water]
[Africans rake leaves, supervised by white man in a hat]
[Scenes in West Africa, West African Yellow Fever Comnmission, Reel 2]
[White man in white clothing walks in front of colonial housing structures and is shown smoking a cigarette]
[Model T automobile pulls up; the white man speaks to the driver through the window]
[A white man emerges from the car]
[White man inspects fruit hanging from a tree]
[Villagers at work and in marketplace, looking at small coin-like objects on display.]
[Men gathered outside of low-slung, thatch-roofed structure]
[Men work at constructing a building]
[White man walks past western-style structure, walks up steps and into building]
[Caucasian man climbs to top of ladder held steady by two other men]
[An African and a westerner inspect a plant; they appear to be conducting mosquito research]
[Men are shown pouring a substance from a flask into a container]
[Man cranks a Model T vehicle in order to start it, then climbs into car]
[The African and the westerner continue their inspection of plants and mosquitos]
[Water is poured into dish]
[The African and the Caucasian appear to compare notes; they stand amongst thick foliage.]
[Standing on a patch of dirt, the Caucasian signals to the African, who brings over a pump.]
[The two men work alongside the riverbank; the African climbs a tree.]
[White man working in lab, examining vials and samples.]
[Villagers of all ages on riverbank, some in water, some working at water's edge, canoe visible in foreground.]
[Panning view of trees and foliage, villagers in canoes.]
[Men in shoulder-deep water, hacking at foliage]
[Villagers in boats, propelling them with poles]
[Villagers gathered at water's edge, images of canoes tied up or heading for the dock.]
[Turbaned man sitting in boat; a second man, standing in the bow, poles the boat forward]
[White man wearing hat speaks to co-worker, an African man who has climbed a tree and gives first one object, then another, to the man on the ground, using his foot. He then climbs down from the tree.]
[Large group of white-robed men walking]
[African man climbs down from tree]
[Villagers of both genders walking about market square]
[White-robed men walk through opening between two structures]
[Dead fowl hangs upside down from branches implanted in ground]
[Two villagers walk through alleyway]
[Villagers of all ages walk through village square, some hoisting parasols, some playing drums]
[White-robed men celebrate, flags waving. A banner is carried through the square, people play instruments.]
[Men on horseback are shown, along with other villagers, walking and celebrating, some carrying drums or parasols.]
[Villagers continue walking across grassy expanse, carrying flags.]
[Person on horseback, dead fowl hanging from branch.]
[Natives moving about village common area.]
[White man tosses something in the air, people rush to compete for it.]
[Images of village dwellings are show, constructed of thatch, mud, sticks. of varying shapes and sizes. A white man is shown in front on one structure.]
[A Visit to Ilesha]
[African men pack cotton into burlap sacks, piles of cotton lie on the ground. A white man stands near one pile of cotton.]
[Three Caucasians, a woman and two men, walk past a western-style strcuture]
[Villagers approach a structure with arches in front and windows with shutters along the side.]
[A woman with a baby strapped to her back walks by; others are shown standing as if waiting.]
[An African and a Caucasian man stride along.]
[Tall trees with palm-like fronds spreading out from the top.]
[Two automobiles approach and cross a small bridge over a culvert.]
[Columned building inscribed at top: Baptist Hospital African Mission USA. Villagers stand and walk in front of hospital.]
[Oyo, The Yoruba Capital]
[Field dotted with foliage and trees, animals grazing in background, people on hillside.]
[Images of village dwellings.]
[Villagers sitting beneath and walking under tree, pounding contents of large bowl with long pestle]
[View through archway of stuccoed building to second building with three archways]
[Woman with headcovering walking through village]
[Woman walking down tree-lined path with bundle on head]
[Livestock moving through field]
[Men herding livestock down road]
[Man who appears not to have use of his legs propels himself on his hands]
[People milling about outside western-style building situated alongside lane with trees on both sides]
[Automobile approaches and passes villagers walking on road]
[People hurrying across grass toward tree canopy]
[Villagers, many with bundles on heads, are gathered and moving about together, wood is lying on the ground]
[A man looks at a woman seated on the ground with handmade bowls spread out before her]
[Villagers in marketplace]
[Panaromic view of village roofs, valley, cinderblock structures]
[Villagers walking in square, scrubbing clothing in creek]
[People lying in beds in hospital ward]
[Thatch-roofed structure buttressed by logs]
[Crocodile]
[Naked boy on riverbank with Caucasian man standing a few feet behind him]
[People walking near culvert and stream.]
[Boy dipping water out of a puddle while Caucasian in white hat examines an instrument he is holding]
[Area outside village huts, with large vases and a chicken pecking in the background]
[Women walking with bundles on their heads]
[Child with a vase on his head; another child stands behind him with a cloth draped over his head]
[Women washing clothes at water's edge]
[Man leads large bird by the beak]
[Men sitting on ground amongst livestock]
[Images of furs, small dishes of food]
[Panoramic view of long, low, western-style structure and other buildings on shoreline]
[Men in boats, shadowy image of two men piloting a vessel]
[View of water from vessel]
[Men in small fishing boats, plying the waters]
[Images of village huts, child walks by]
[View of water, seemingly filmed from moving boat]
[Huts at water's edge]
[Close-up views of thatch-roofed huts]
[White man seated on stool, villagers standing nearby.]
[Several African men, some in western-type clothing, others in robes, face the camera directly.]
[Several men in a boat, two of them rowing]
[Huts at water's edge]
[View of water, seemingly filmed from moving boat]
[Men tossing out fishing nets from boats]
[Scenes in West Africa, West African Yellow Fever Commission, Reel 4]
[Westerners walk across field past horse]
[African troops are lined up. A crowd of spectators occupies stands overlooking field. Caucasians and Africans in civilian and military garb walk across the field.]
[African troops march slowly across field, then pick up the pace and march faster]
[Several white men approach an automobile parked in the middle of the field. African soliders stand at attention nearby.]
[British officer with medals pinned to uniform walks across field]
[Livestock in the street]
[[British officer with medals pinned to uniform walks across field]
[Goat tied to column]
[Street scene, men and children sitting, talking, walking about]
[Men in white robes and turbans walk down street; an automobile drives past them.]
[Men in white robes, some on horseback, some carrying flags, advance down the street]
[Villagers walk quickly, jog, and run down the street, some holding pots above their heads, some carrying flags, playing instruments or singing. The crowd turns and heads in the direction frm which it came.]
[Villagers are gathered near shoreline; canoes are shown in the foreground.]
[Men are shown bent to the ground in prayer.]
[A man holding a knife prepares to slaughter an animal held on the ground by other men.]
[Scenes in West Africa, West African Yellow Fever Commission, Reel 3]